[Music]
so living together now yeah the
bachelorette who do you who you pull in
foreign rachel season I believe it's
been really busy and you know I think we
just kind of decompressing off last
season so but you know we hear she he's
engaged so that's awesome I'm very happy
for her and whoever that is
she obviously made the right call cuz
she made it for herself well I
appreciated you know when you guys after
your season was over you're really
honest about like look we're figuring
things out right now so any advice that
you would have a ratio your fiance when
when the show ends slow you know get to
know each other outside about the world
cool and are you gonna be tuning in for
a bachelor in paradise with everybody in
August
a little time off but how can anyone
miss paradise you know I mean all in all
are you surprised about how everything
shook out with the scandal did you think
that the show was gonna come back I mean
I was hopeful you know I think it sounds
like they did the right thing by you
know investigating whatever it was and
it's just good to see that it's back
[Music]